really early on in gim frers we were
like about a million a month we go to
this like operations coach and so he's
like I want you both to write down
everything you do on this whiteboard
everything you do in the business we
both write down everything that we do
every single day and there's this column
that says Alex and Lila he takes the
marker and he circles like 90% of the
things on the board and he's like Lea
this is all yours this is Alex's and I
was like I love this guy ilila is a pure
operator like a pure Thoroughbred
operator she's unbelievable and I
usually operate best when I just have
space and time and if I have space and
time I come up with a couple good ideas
it's just like hey what if we did this
and then Lila's like I got it and then I
guess Tak can care